Arrêtez ! ça me gêne ! Il y a certaines
jungles qu’on se plait à regarder à la
TV dans The Island ou Koh Lanta, mais il y
en a d’autres qui divisent beaucoup plus.
Oui parce que quand des migrants sont bloqués
à Calais, on parle de Jungle. Jungle ? Cyrusly?!
Et la jungle on sait tous ce que c’est,
c’est une forêt tropicale avec pleins d’animaux
sauvages et indomptables, des plantes exotiques
mortelles, et des aborigènes qui te visent
à la sarbacane. Alors que c’est pas un
endroit fait pour vivre, c’est fait pour
survivre. D’ailleurs, tant qu’on parle
de vocabulaire, j’aimerai éclaircir un
point. On parle souvent indifféremment de
migrants et de réfugiés. Hors, les deux
termes sont très différents. D’abord le
réfugié, en droit international c’est
le statut officiel d’une personne qui a
obtenu l’asile d’un Etat tiers. Le migrant
lui, c'est quelqu'un qui effectue une migration,
c’est-à-dire qui se déplace volontairement
dans un autre pays ou une autre région pour
des raisons économiques, politiques ou culturelles.
Bref, globalement les réfugiés sont des
migrants, mais tout migrant n'est pas un réfugié.
C'est pourquoi, dans la suite de cette vidéo,
comme à Calais il n’y a pas que des réfugiés,
je parlerai de migrants, mais je trouvais
ça important de se poser au moins la question.
Du coup, la “jungle” de Calais que vous
avez vue dans tous les JT, c’est près de
six mille migrants bloqués près de la frontière
anglaise, a quelques kilomètres du centre
ville de Calais. Et si on en parle autant
en ce moment c’est suite à l’accélération
des décisions de justice entraînant l’évacuation
d’une partie du camp et sa destruction au
tractopelle. Mais avant qu’on rentre dans
le détail, c’est important qu’on se pose
et qu’on explique ce que c’est que cette
Jungle et pourquoi elle existe. Déjà on
peut la voir simplement comme un camp de migrants
et réfugiés qui s’est installé au fur
et à mesure à proximité de la ville de
Calais. Et ça date pas d’hier, sauf si
vous regardez cette vidéo en 1999. Ce qui n’aurait absolument aucun sens.
Ce qui s’est passé à ce moment là,
c’est qu’il y a eu un afflux de personnes
provenant du Kosovo en guerre, et qu’on
a créé un centre d'accueil à Sangatte,
une commune qui est à côté de Calais. Du
coup l'État y a réquisitionné un hangar
de vingt sept mille mètres carrés appartenant
à Eurotunnel et la gestion du centre a été
confiée à la Croix-Rouge. L’idée c’était
que les migrants puissent attendre dans le
hangar, le temps qu’on leur donne les autorisations
nécessaires. Sauf que c’est devenu de plus
en plus difficile d’avoir une autorisation,
donc ça a bloqué, et on se retrouve à mille
huit cent dans un centre prévu pour accueillir
huit cent personnes. Imaginez la crise du
logement à Paris, sauf qu’il n’y a pas
de logement. Et que c’est pas à Paris.
Pour vous donner une idée, en trois ans,
Sangatte a vu passer près de soixante huit
mille migrants. Ya du passage, et ça ça
dure jusqu’en deux mille deux, après on
ferme le centre de Sangatte et on le détruit.
Parce qu’on a enfin trouvé une solution
et donc il y en avait plus besoin ! Enfin
c’est ce que j’aurai aimé dire mais en
fait non, les politiques l’ont juste détruit
pour le symbole. En réalité, la fermeture
du centre a laissé place à ce que l’on
appelle la "jungle de Calais". Donc depuis
la création du camp, le problème n’a jamais
été réglé, ça a juste changé de nom
ce qui fait que ça embrouillé l’opinion
publique. C’est le retour de réfugiés
en masse qui est nouveau. Par contre ya une
question que tout le monde se pose c’est
: “On a du Saint Tropez, du Quiberon, des
putains de stations de Skis, et Paris Plage
! Pourquoi ils vont tous à Calais ?!” Bah
en fait, attention spoiler, ils sont pas là
pour prendre du bon temps, ils veulent juste
aller en Angleterre. Le pays du pudding, du
poisson panné, et de la naissance du premier
partenariat de Kway avec une météo locale.
Je déconne pas, c’est celle de la semaine
dernière, et j’aurai pu faire cette vanne
en août j’aurai pas eu besoin de changer
d’insert. Non, ce qu’il faut comprendre
c’est que la plupart des arrivants ont des
liens familiaux ou culturels avec le Royaume-Uni.
quarante six pourcent des migrants calaisiens
ont déclaré avoir suivi les conseils de
leur communauté dans ce choix de destination,
et trente huit pourcent ont un membre de leur
famille installé en Angleterre. Donc oui,
en gros, le Royaume-Uni attire beaucoup plus
les migrants que la France, ils ont de la
famille là bas, il parlent anglais, c’est
plus simple d’y trouver un job, du coup
ils ont pas pour but de s’intégrer en France.
C’est une partie du problème aussi. Du
coup on a des populations qui rentrent en
Europe par plein de portes différentes et
qui se retrouvent bloquées à la frontière
anglaise, chez nous. Pour vous dresser le
tableau, il y a peut être cinq mille trois
cent personnes en train de faire du camping
près de la mer du nord, mais on est loin
du camp de vacances. Faut déjà imaginer
un camp entre un marais et une autoroute.
Les familles sont dans des tentes. Les sanitaires
n’ont de sanitaire que le nom. Et ce qui
sert d’épicerie n’est là que pour les
nécessité. Parce que oui dans ces conditions,
je peux concevoir que le Red Bull soit une
nécessité. En plus de ce qu’on voit là,
ils baignent dans un environnement assez violent,
et à tous les niveaux : violences policières,
violences de militants d’extrême droite,
violence entre migrants. La situation est
complexe, et notamment pour les femmes et
les enfants. Plusieurs associations comme
Médecins du Monde ou Médecins Sans Frontières
ont dénoncé de graves atteintes à la Santé
et aux Droits des Femmes. Et il y a des violences
multiples : viols, prostitution, grossesses
non désirées, infections sexuellement transmissibles
et du coup il y a des zones sanctuarisées
et sécurisées qui leur sont maintenant réservé.
T’as même certains pères seuls avec leurs
enfants qui les ont confiés à des mères
dans ces sanctuaires afin de les préserver.
On est en France. Et depuis plusieurs mois,
la situation s’envenime. Les migrants s’appuient
sur des réseaux de passeurs pour tenter de
rejoindre l’Angleterre, sauf que les passeurs
sont organisés, ils profitent de la situation
et ils squattent eux aussi la zone. Les mecs
développent un véritable business estimé
entre trois et six milliards d’euros sur
l’ensemble de l’Europe. Alors, le chiffre
peut paraitre abstrait mais il vous parlera
peut-être mieux si je vous dit que le PIB
de Monaco était de cinq virgule trente deux
milliards en deux mille quatorze. C’est
juste hallucinant. Et les mecs vont même
jusque développer des filières low cost
à cinq cent euros le passage vers l’Angleterre
à bord d’un camion qui ne leur appartient
évidemment pas. Je serai pas surpris que
parfois ce soit eux-même qui les conduisent.
Le Ryanair de l’immigration clandestine.
Non parce que vous avez sûrement déjà vu
des images de migrants qui essaient de passer
vers le Royaume-Uni, en montant dans des camions,
des ferrys, voire même en essayant de s’introduire
dans le tunnel sous la Manche. Et bien c’est
souvent via ces réseaux de passeurs. Et c’est
fréquent puisqu’il y a eu trente mille
tentatives d’intrusions en dix mois d’après
Eurotunnel. Et franchement je comprends cette
volonté de partir. Le problème c’est que
la jungle de Calais c’est pas celle de Jumanji,
t’en sort pas avec un cinq ou un six. Les
points de passage sont bloqués et la vie
doit s’organiser sur place. Du coup, inévitablement,
ça impacte directement la population locale.
Parce qu’ils ne faut pas oublier que cette
situation fait peser sur tout Calais et ses
environs. Les chauffeurs de camion par exemple,
doivent vérifier chaque centimètre carré
de leur camion, passer par des procédures
de vérifications aux douanes beaucoup plus
complexes, et se retrouvent parfois confrontés
à des attaques. Et ça en rend fou certains
! J’aurai jamais pensé qu’un bord de
route puisse avoir une mauvaise ambiance ! Et
à Calais c’est pire, c’est la vie de
la population qui est directement touchée.
La maire de Calais, en porte-parole, parle
d’une prise d’otage des calaisiens. Ce
qui se comprend, parce que les arguments sont
nombreux et ça va du sentiment d’insécurité
à l’impression d’afflux dans les hôpitaux
à cause des conditions de vie dans les camps,
surtout que les gens sont à bout ! Ils subissent
le même problème depuis quinze ans les mecs
! Calais c’est soixante douze mille habitants,
on parlait de six mille migrants tout à l’heure,
donc un peu moins de dix pourcents. Donc bien
évidemment que ça créer des tensions ! Bon,
une ville joyeuse, ne nous emballons pas mais
c’est vrai qu’il y a toute une population
qui vivait grâce au tourisme. Aujourd’hui,
les commerçants et restaurateurs sont dans
une situation difficile et subissent l’image
de zone de guerre perpétuellement véhiculée
par les médias ! En seulement quelques mois,
le secteur de la restauration a diminué de
quarante pourcents et les commerces de détail
de vingt pourcents. C’est beaucoup ! Et
du coup bah qu’est-ce qui se passe dans
une zone qui se sent délaissée depuis quinze
ans ? Et bien les gens essaient de prendre
les choses en main et les manifestations anti
ou pro migrants à Calais deviennent fréquentes,
comme sur cette séquence qui a buzzé il
y a plusieurs semaines où on voit un habitant
sortir avec son fusil. Donc si on résume
pour l’instant ! On a des migrants et des
réfugiés empaquetés qui vivent dans des
conditions horribles, des Calaisiens qui sont
à bout, et une situation qui s’envenime
et s’enlise. C’est hyper complexe. En
fait pour bien comprendre Calais, il va falloir
dezoomer un peu et regarder le problème dans
sa globalité. Calais c’est une conséquence
directe de la crise des migrants qui secoue
l’europe depuis les années deux mille dix,
bien résumée ici par cette carte que je
vous mets en description. L'Organisation Internationale
pour les Migrants (OIM) annonce aujourd'hui
que, depuis janvier deux mille seize, plus
de cent mille migrants sont arrivés en Europe
via la Méditerranée. En deux mille quinze,
ce chiffre n'avait été atteint qu'en juin
alors que c’était déjà une année où
on avait vécu une explosion du nombre d’arrivée.
Et sur ces cent mille, plus de quatre vingt
dix pourcents sont arrivés en Grèce qui
évidemment ne peut les recevoir. Non parce
que je vous rappelle que les Grecs sont pas
au top niveau thunes et moyens d’accueil.
Du coup les proportions de ce problème sont
juste énormes. En fait Calais c’est un
point de crispation autour d’une crise bien
plus globale. Et cette crise globale, c’est
avant tout une crise politique. L’Europe
est archi divisée sur la question. L’Allemagne,
pour des raisons principalement économiques
et démographiques, a choisi d’accueillir
plus d’un million de migrants avant de freiner
le rythme des entrées et elle est favorable
à un système de répartition par quotas,
alors que la France, par exemple, est contre.
Et t’en a d’autres, comme la Hongrie qui
veulent même pas entendre parler de migrants.
Plus qu’une crise migratoire, c’est une
crise de volontés nationales. Et cette crise
a des conséquences directes sur l’europe
politique. Il y a par exemple, ponctuellement
des fermetures de frontières par effet domino.
Comme il n’y a pas de décisions communes,
les décisions se font au niveau des différents
pays, et chaque décision d’un pays a des
conséquences dans les pays voisins. Par exemple,
en prévision de la possible évacuation d’une
partie de la jungle de Calais, la Belgique
a rétabli les contrôles aux frontières
avec la France il y a quelques semaines. Ou
encore, la Macédoine, un petit pays qui fait
de la salade, vient de décider de ne plus
laisser entrer les migrants Afghans, les obligeant
à rester en Grèce, créant un nouveau méga-Calais
en Grèce ce qui est beaucoup moins drôle
que les Chtis à Mykonos. C’est pour ça
qu’un camp deux fois plus grand que Calais
est né à Idoméni, où s’entassent désormais
plus de onze mille migrants. C’est énorme.
Et cet effet domino de frontières va jusqu’à
la Turquie, point de passage obligé pour
les migrants et réfugiés Syriens notamment.
Du coup ça bloque aussi, et il y a aujourd’hui
plus de deux millions de Syriens, c’est
à dire dix pourcents de la population de
la Syrie d’avant guerre, qui vivent en Turquie
et en Jordanie. Pour vous donner une idée,
les camps en Jordanie, ça ressemble à ça.
Quatre vingt mille syriens dans le camp de
Zaatani en Jordanie. Tu prends Calais, tu
multiplies par dix. Et c’est là que tu
réalises que Calais à côté, c’est pas
une jungle, c’est un terrain de mini-golf
dans le Lot et Garonne. Donc quand j’entends
“les migrants dehors” ou “fermons nos
frontières” je trouve ça déconnecté
de la réalité ! Calais, c’est pas nouveau,
c’est un phénomène qu’on a déjà connu,
et qu’on connaîtra à nouveau tant qu’il
y aura des guerres à nos portes. C’est
mathématique quoi. C’est le théorème
de Calais. Genre quand t’as une guerre et
que t’as une partie de la population civile
qui est touchée, ben cette population fuit
son pays pour d’autres territoires où elle
a des attaches. Par contre c’est pas parce
que c’est logique que c’est souhaitable
ni pour les Calaisiens mais surtout pour les
migrants qui se tape des trajets incroyablements
dangereux pour , ça ne l’est pas du tout
et on peut peut être y faire quelque chose.
Et je prends pas trop de risques en disant
que c’est ni le démantèlement du camps
et le relogement des personnes concernées,
ni le changement de politique de gestion des
frontières extérieures de l’UE qui à
eux seuls vont régler ce problème de manière
durable. Et la preuve, c’est qu’à peine
une partie de la jungle évacuée, un autre
camp vient d’être ouvert à Grande-Synthe.
Pour l’anecdote il avait une capacité de
mille cint cent personnes et il était complet
en une semaine. Donc on a une situation qui
n’est pas souhaitable et aucune solution
simple. Et bien pour trouver des pistes, c’est
tout bête, on va reprendre certains problèmes.
Déjà celui des passeurs qui à mon sens
est assez grave puisque indirectement ils
alimentent cet afflux vu que c’est dans
leur intérêt que les gens aient la volonté
d’aller en Angleterre. Du coup si on arrive
à démanteler les réseaux de passeurs, on
atténue le phénomène qu’on observe à
Calais. De la même manière il faut sensibiliser
les migrants à la réalité de Calais et
la réalité de la frontière anglaise. Il
y a de nombreux migrants qui regrettent d’être
venus et veulent rentrer chez eux. ça c’est
aussi un vrai problème. L’information.
Ensuite un autre soucis c’est la mésentente
européenne : il faudrait que les pays d’Europe
calment leurs égos nationaux respectifs,
pour mettre en place une réponse plus coordonnée.
Pour l’instant, l’Europe arrive à se
mettre d’accord uniquement pour aller demander
à la Turquie de retenir les migrants, en
échange d’aides financières et autres
concessions en tout genre. Pour tout le reste,
l’Europe se déchire. Pourtant, répartir
quelques millions de personnes au sein d’une
Europe qui compte plus de cinq cent millions
d’habitants, ça semble pas être hallucinant.
Et c’est hyper dommage, parce que l’Europe
c’est fait pour des problèmes comme ça,
c’est sur ce genre de trucs qu’on l’attend.
Non seulement l’Europe ne prend pas cette
direction, mais elle en prend la direction
contraire, en se fracturant plus que jamais
sur des questions identitaires, en s’occupant
comme elle peut avec les Brexit, c’est le
fait que la Grande Bretagne sorte de l’Europe,
la crise de l’euro, sanctions contre la
Russie, entre autres ! Autant de sujets qui
divisent les opinions publiques et font monter
les extrêmes, affaiblissant les démocraties
européennes en les empêchant de parler d’une
voix forte. Le problème de Calais n’a pas
de chances, c’est un problème qui s’étend
sur des dizaines d’années, qui est assez
local, tous les ingrédients sont là pour
que les gens l’oublient. S’il y a une
vraie solution elle est bien à l’extérieur
de Calais. Et elle est dans la paix. Calais
nous fait prendre conscience que nous vivons
dans un monde globalisé, même au niveau
migratoire malgré des frontières apparentes,
et ce qui se passe dans un pays à l’autre
bout du monde, peut avoir des répercussions
sur un village du Nord de la France. Ces problèmes
là devraient nous concerner d’avantages,
avant que ça prenne l’ampleur qu’on voit
là. Parce que qu’on le veuille ou non,
on vit dans un monde ou de plus en plus, jusque
dans les faits, le problème des autres, c’est
notre problème aussi.